-Finally, we have
exactly 10 shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters."
-♪ 12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Ten days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
an exquisite Christmas sweater
from the Countdown to Christmas
Cabinet.
Now, since there are
10 shows left,
let's open door number 10.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ready for this?
Ooh! [ Laughs ]
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is --
Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
Alright.
Now let's see who's gonna
go home with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drum roll, please?
[ Drum roll ]
Who wants this sweater?!
It's a good one!
[ Cheers and applause ]
216!
Come on! Come on!
♪♪
Come on! How you doing?
Nice to see you. How are you?
Why don't you stand over there?
Here you go.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-I'm Leah. I'm from Germany.
-Yeah! Leah from Germany!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow. We love Germany.
Thanks for coming to the show.
I appreciate this.
It gets cold in Germany, right?
-It does.
-Yeah.
Do you have anything like this?
-Not yet.
-Yeah.
Would you like to try it on?
-Absolutely.
-Yeah. Here. Go for it.
This is gonna be fun.
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You're -- It's very --
Oh, yeah!
This is good.
Wow!
Stunning! Stunning!
Gorgeous!
That's what I'm talking about.
Thank you so much
for being here.
I appreciate this.
Let's give our winner a round
of applause. Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Selena Gomez, everybody!
Come on back!
♪♪